Victor Cohen spent five years in the NFL
he has his own cigar line he's an actor
and now he's starting a really cool car
show called cigars and cars Victor
thanks for joining us man tell us about
this huge car show that's happening this
weekend well basically um we just
launched a group in August so it's
called the cigars and cars group it's a
division of my cigar brand BBC cigars
and we're also a wholesaler but it's
open to the public so anyone that has a
zyde card new school old school as you
can see what's going on here
you're more than welcome to come out
bring your children it's going to be a
great time for everyone and where is it
taking place this weekend um is that a
place called Gambit it's a nice facility
and Sunset and um
it has a speakeasy you have to go see it
if you guys ever been to Gambit you got
to come see it and you're gonna have
amazing cars like this back here so
we've got a Model T back here this is
Tom you're the owner what year is this
this is a 1915 Model T Runabout that got
chance changed into a pickup truck okay
something like this so they came out in
1908 the Model T something like this
sold new back then for about 800 which
is about three thousand dollars today
electric start crank start this is a
crank start in 1915 there was no starter
and then in 1919 they invented the
starter and this has a 1919 starter in
it so you can just start it with a
button this is a piece of History how
original is this car this is not a
purest car but it's as pure as you can
get and still run on the road we go
Southern Nevada Model T club we go to
breakfast every Saturday somewhere
online in this Valley that's fantastic
we have another one back here this is
Victor you have some great cars coming
out on Sunday all kinds of cars and this
is this is a racer how old is this car
this was uh born in 24 and then it was
modified at some time and it started
life and a car looked similar to that
one
and uh and then it was turned into a
race car so it now has like a hundred
horsepower instead of 20 horsepower but
Lance look at the inside step one second
let's look inside this car imagine
Victor I mean first off could you fit
inside this vehicle uh no I could not
how many years did you spend in the NFL
five and this is this is not a this is
not a vehicle for an NFL player we're
having a little signal issue so the
event is this weekend Victor thank you
so much Rocky we'll send it back to you
guys